I'm determined we'll definitely be at
that table in six months time we need to
be right because that's what our members
want from us and we remember membership
organization are you really confident
CBI can survive
to be leading those conversations I am
really confident that CBI can survive
it's not going to be the same CBI that
that we've seen over the past few weeks
for sure and it's not going to be the
same organization uh that's been there
we have to completely change and we will
we were aware of any of this toxicity in
the world do you have any concerns that
this kind of thing might have been going
on when you were working here
look when I was here I you know if if
people raised issues with me with me I
supported them and and I think and look
this is really challenging right and
when things happen to an organization
and the stories we have heard are so
harrowing right and and everyone feels
them really deeply they're shocking
they're painful what practically do you
do to start changing the culture
I think it starts with listening
starts with humility
and I think that's you know what's
really hard coming into this job uh as a
leader is I have to come into this job
and I've got a staff you know and people
who are broken who've gone through a
really really terrible time and I think
what is difficult in this organization
in particular right is when things
happen it's it's in the news every day
people wake up and read about themselves
their organization their staff every day
in the newspapers and then they have to
come in and deliver their job and it's
really really tough and it's really
personal right